-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You're watching.
Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, everyone's excited
about this --
the 95th Oscars are this Sunday.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Yeah.
I love the Oscars
because it's the one time
we get to make James Cameron sit
in a theater for five hours.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ten movies are nominated
for Best Picture,
including "Top Gun: Maverick,"
"Avatar" 2, "Elvis,"
and seven other films
that you lied about seeing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This will be Jimmy Kimmel's
third time hosting the Oscars.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Which means it will also be
the third time
my dad calls the next day like,
"You did a great job
hosting the Oscars.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You got funny all of a sudden,
huh?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the Oscars
are finally here.
For everyone nominated,
just remember --
even if you don't win,
Fox News might say you did.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Ohhs and cheering ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Preach!
[ Whistling and applause ]
-Well, as you probably heard,
the White House and Congress
are talking
about banning TikTok.
[ Oohs ]
They're worried about China
spying on us,
so, it might be outlawed.
Yeah, so, they're trying
to take it down,
but I have a feeling
it might stay put.
Kind of like --
[ Cheering ]
[ Ohhs and laughter ]
I mean, people
really love TikTok.
It'd be hard to watch it go
down in flames.
Sort of like --
Whee-un!
[ Ohhs ]
Whee--
[ Screaming ]
[ Rimshot ]
-It raises --
It raises so many questions.
Will TikTok be totally gone
or will parts of it remain?
Kind of like --
-Oh, no!
[ Ohhs ]
[ Screaming and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Or like --
[ Sighs ]
[ Ohhs ]
[ Laughter ]
Either way,
you can feel the tension
getting high, almost like --
[ Clattering ]
[ Ohhs ]
-Olivia, you [bleep] idiot!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Long --
[ Laughs ]
Long story short,
if TikTok is outlawed,
it'll leave a giant hole
in our hearts.
Kind of like --
[ Laughter ]
[ Gasps ]
[ Ohhs ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
My favorite.
-What?
-His head just went
through the wall, yeah.
It's the best.
Some more political news --
it sounds like
former President Trump
will likely
face criminal charges
for his hush money payments
to Stormy Daniels.
[ Oohs ]
Trump was like --
[ As Trump ]
I've never regretted
30 seconds more in my life.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Right now,
Democrats are thinking,
"Wow, it's like we're getting
two Oscars in one week."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Switching gears --
I saw that South Korea
is building the world's biggest
spokeless Ferris wheel.
[ Oohs ]
Can we see a photo?
Look at this.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
It looks like God's aura ring.
You actually have one of those
aura rings, don't you?
-Yeah, I did.
-You don't like it?
-I didn't care for at all.
-Why?
-Always said I was asleep
and it hurt so bad to put it on.
It hurt really bad.
[ Laughter ]
-What finger do you have it on?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Never mind.
-Supposed to go --
Just cut away,
cut away from me, cut away.
We can cut this out.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ohhh!
-God.
Terrible.
-You're supposed to put it
on your finger?
-You got to read --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Now, it makes sense.
-Read the instructions.
-Yeah.
-You have to read
the instructions.
-Ouch!
-You just went
with your instinct on it.
-Yeah. Figured, why not?
-Yeah.
No, no, no, no.
-Oof!
-Well, this is going viral --
supermarket chain Aldi
has new Easter bunny
marshmallow snacks,
but some people have noticed
they don't really look
like bunnies.
Check this out here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Even worse, they slapped on
a warning label that says,
"May contain nuts."
-Oh, hey!
[ Rimshot ]
It's the only Easter candy
that's perfect for Easter
and a bachelorette party.
-Oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
You should put an aura
ring on it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Don't put it on those.
-♪ If you want it, you gotta
put an aura ring on it ♪
-Finally...
[ Laughter ]
...a burglar in the UK
was identified
after leaving his birth
certificate at a crime scene.
[ Laughter ]
Forget leaving it
at a crime scene.
Who walks around with their
birth certificate?
[ Laughter ]
Right now, police are
on the lookout
for a man who weighs
7 pounds, 3 ounces.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show.
Let's go write
some thank you notes.
Come on with me.
Come on.
-♪ JKLMNOP ♪
♪ [ Indistinct ] ♪
♪ But freeze ♪
♪ Catch the wave, later ♪
♪ That was like the alphabet,
but I'm an Alpha Beta ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-What a show!
What a show we have
for you tonight.
She stars in the new movie
"Shazam! Fury of the Gods,"
which opens in theaters
and IMAX March 17th.
Our pal Lucy Liu
is here tonight!
-Yeah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I love Lucy Liu.
-Yeah.
You can see him
in the FX series "Snowfall,"
which airs Wednesdays
and streams the next day
on Hulu.
Damson Idris is joining us!
-Yeah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Stud.
Studly show.
Plus, we've got some great,
great, great music.
He's a five-time
Latin Grammy-nominated producer
and she is the best-selling
female Latin artist of all time.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh!
-All time!
-♪ Shakira, Shakira ♪
-Their new song,
"music sessions vol. 53"
is out now.
and breaking records everywhere.
Music superstars Bizarrap
and Shakira
-Oh!
-are here tonight!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Come on!
-We're going to talk to them
and they're performing for us
later in the show.
-Oy!
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Guys, today is Friday
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
return some emails,
and, of course, I send out
thank you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I was running a bit behind.
I was wondering, can I write out
some thank you notes right now?
Is that okay with you guys?
[ Cheering and applause ]
I appreciate it.
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
Daylight Savings this Sunday,
for kicking off
that special half of the year
when our microwaves are actually
set to the right time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, yeah!
-I knew it!
-Oh!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Apple,
for releasing a new
yellow iPhone
and basically saying, "Look,
there's only so many cameras
we can slap
on the back of this thing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't know.
It's yellow."
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, au jus,
for sounding like
a really fancy sneeze.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Au jus!
[ Laughter ]
-Gesundheit.
-[ Chuckles ]
Oui oui.
[ Laughter ]
Could you wee-wee
when you had your --
-No.
-No, you couldn't.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ French accent ] No, no.
-That's probably why
it's painful.
-Well, it was weird
because it was European, so.
[You're a-peein']
[ Laughter ]
You know, French.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Korn and Toys"R"Us,
for keeping the backward "R"
industry alive.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Respect.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, light blinking
on my Wi-Fi router,
for either meaning
it's completely broken
or working perfectly.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's blinking.
That's a good thing.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Entenmann's,
for bringing back
the see-through window
on your boxes...
[ Laughter ]
...or, as doughnuts call you,
the red light district.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Mmm!
♪♪
-[ Baritone ]
Donut hole.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, finding the light
switch in the dark,
for letting me get
to third base with the wall.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my Thank You Notes.